la propuesta del gobierno de venezuela
de incorporar como miembro pleno en las
negociaciones que se desarrollan en
mexico con la oposición a alexa tiene
señalado de ser testaferro del chavismo
se da luego de que hace una semana el
tribunal constitucional de cabo verde
dictaminó que estaba debería ser
extraditado a estados unidos donde es
requerido por presunto lavado de dinero
desde que ésta fue detenido en cabo
verde en junio del año pasado el
gobierno de venezuela ha exigido su
libertad y ha calificado su detención
como secuestro el lunes- baltasar garzón
quien es miembro del equipo legal
internacional de álex up había dicho que
este caso podría incidir negativamente
en el diálogo que se desarrolla en
mexico para la defensa en este caso es
una persecución jurídica contra una
persona que a su juicio tiene una
incidencia principal en las relaciones
de venezuela y eeuu hasta ahora la
oposición de este país no se ha referido
al tema en france 24 si consultamos
analistas políticos que consideran que
esto es una jugada del gobierno que pone
en riesgo y sabotea el proceso de
negociación y que ésta buscando además
que sea la oposición quien se levante de
la mesa de diálogo por la presencia de
alexa